the killing of Qasem Soleimani and its
consequences continues to reverberate
around the American political scene
President Donald Trump claimed in a
televised interview and Friday for US
embassies were an imminent risk of
Iranian attack that he said justified
the operation but US defense secretary
Marquez but was far less certain there
was one piece of intelligence that
pointed in that direction I didn't see
one with regard to four embassies what
I'm saying is I assure the president's
view that probably my expectation was
they were going to go after our
embassies the embassies the most
prominent display of American presence
in a country one of the embassies at
risk believed to be the one in Baghdad
the president's national security
adviser insists the threat to four was
real the intelligence they were working
with was in his words exquisite because
of the prompt action that we took both
with respect to the embassy in Baghdad
which they would have attempted to
overrun and storm and with respect to
our our military bases that were hit by
the Iranians with their ballistic
missiles there was no loss of American
life in either case and I think that's a
credit the president United States but
in Capitol Hill both Republicans and
Democrats have been critical of the
intelligence briefing they were given
Democrat Adam Schiff chair of the House
Intelligence Committee stopped just
short of accusing the Trump
administration of lying to Congress the
brief it was much more along the lines
frankly of something the secretary
Pompeo admitted the other day when he
said that we don't know precisely where
and we know know precisely when
Republican Senator Rand Paul a trump
supporter said there was no evidence an
attack was imminent and insisted
Congress must act to limit further
action against Iran so my point in being
for this War Powers debate is that we
really need to have a debate about
whether we should still be in Iraq or in
Afghanistan and there needs to be
authorized ation from Congress the US
House of Representatives has approved a
War Powers Resolution
aimed at limiting future military action
against Iran by the Trump administration
there's no sign it's about to be debated
in the Senate Allen Fisher al Jazeera
Washington